let's get this party started
um
we
have a first guest um she's an
emmy-nominated actress and um we've all
come to
love her in the addicting super
binge-worthy show search party which is
like just so had been cool and fun and
uh you can also see her playing john
cena's girlfriend in a movie that's
going to make you all super lol which i
don't know about you but comedy is my
medicine
it's called vacation friends i hear it's
kind of naughty too which i'm really
into take a look
get comfortable oh and if you guys are
worried about privacy and you want to
like get really kinky tonight we're
extremely loud i don't know what these
walls are made of but you seriously
can't hear anything
okay listen
you're not gonna believe this
i just screamed in there
welcome meredith
[Applause]
by the way okay here's a fun fact we
actually did a movie together
um many years ago now my uh my first
anything
yeah it was my first movie okay it's
called going the distance uh i did it
with uh the actor justin long there's
the poster
and we have a clip so let's take a look
really quick you're going to want to put
this on your hands especially under your
nails unless you like want your hands
stained right this way okay
enjoy this
a really huge roll
by the way you're really funny and
dismissive and like perfect i hope the
director nanette like was so gracious to
you about your beautiful performance i
mean it was like my first line in
anything and so i tried to like not make
a meal out of it which i think is one of
the harder jobs when you have like one
line which i had a lot of years of being
like the person with one line but i
think i came in and i was like where do
you think my character's coming from
they're probably like probably the desk
right
you're like no i mean you know like
what's her story what's her relationship
with her mom you know they're like
you're literally came from the desk and
you're here to serve a very real purpose
which is to give him cream for his hands
okay so you and your husband wyatt yeah
um
you just had a baby seven months ago
yeah
how was it being pregnant during oh
i was like the baby no that's my husband
i know isn't he so cute he's really cute
he's such a great dad too he's a good
egg really oh yeah he's so great i guess
you don't know going into it you're like
i hope you but he was like second mom i
mean the baby was actually kind of he
was so he was like baby whisper and
bonding so well with the baby and then
the baby found him funnier which i was
like really personally offended by
um
but yeah he was he was so he's such a
good dad oh my gosh and okay what was it
like being pregnant during the pandemic
i i think pregnancy is so intimidating
it's such an interesting thing to stay
in your own lane and not look at how
other people are doing it and be like it
just for me it was the word i kept
saying over and over was just surrender
like just surrender because there's no
you never know it's just we're all
living in this unprecedented time and
being pregnant through it you're like
this is just just release surrender and
then um
yeah i had to do so the movie vacation
friends i shot it when i was like up to
eight months pregnant
really you know during the night in that
at all well in that shot i was eight
months pregnant they like wrapped a
thing there's it's a fun easter egg for
the audience to try to track like a
40-pound weight gain between scenes um
i mean
what's strength
during a pandemic
working while you're pregnant
these are herculean efforts
[Music]
it feels so good
now you and your husband um actually met
the way that your in-laws met yeah so
your husband is wyatt russell son to
kurt and goldie
and they met on swing shift yeah what
was it like to
actually have a model of love with two
people we've all known to come and
admire so much well it's so funny
because i think just knowing them i kind
of forget who they are because they're
just just such doubt i mean everybody
says that they're just the most
down-to-earth cool fun normal people and
they're just such they're an amazing
couple so of course that's always nice
to
look at and you got married at their
house right we did in colorado yeah and
it was a theme it was kind of i wanted
it to be like a barefoot type backyard
barbecue we had barbecue it was very
chill and fun and it was the best night
it really was sounds like a western
family it was it was western it was
there was a lot of cowboy hats okay now
one of the things i really want to do
this year is
how the pandemic uh changed me or
prompted me to do something that i would
have never done otherwise and it did
something for you and wyatt you guys uh
maybe got in a car yeah we have a van we
lived in our van for a chunk of it um
and i grew up backpacking so i used to
do a lot of i did like a chunk of the
appalachian trail and so i was always
been like a camper and um and then we
got this van it was the greatest thing
we've ever done it's been so fun um okay
so vacation friends i'm super excited
about it it's a comedy we need that yeah
can you tell me a funny or like anything
about john cena i'm so obsessed with him
he's the greatest person ever and he is
totally like an anomaly you've never met
anyone like him he's like the he's
brilliant he's he looks like you know
he's strong and he's one of the smartest
people like between setups he'll
literally be like i'm like you know you
have like 10 minutes and i just sit
there with my jaw unhinged like
scrolling instagram it's super
depressing and john's like i just worked
on my mandarin and uh played piano and
i'm like what
he's literally like one of those people
like you know people on set where
they're like i just taught at pilates
class and you're like how they're like i
just ran five miles you're like what
he's one of those people and he's always
bettering himself and he's so wise he
gave me a lot of really great advice and
he's just one of the all-time greats
well another show that you're on search
party is like i mean it is like the it
show people love respect binge
like say
what is it like being a part of a show
that's so like highly regarded well you
know what's so funny because we've been
doing it for like five seasons now and
it's just a it's we're all truly good
friends and it's it's one of those
experiences where i know i'm gonna look
back on with such gratitude because it's
so special um okay congratulations on
that
gonna okay um to a quick commercial
break okay and when we come back i'm
really excited
because
you're gonna give me some tips on
something which is very passionate about
please tell me
we're gonna talk about how you can like
do some cool interior stuff on the
cheeks
[Music]